in some ways I think it's quite
disappointing seeing these bars because
the gold is an exciting element it has
interesting chemistry and it's just
sitting here doing nothing
its enormous ly impressive but it's a
bit sad rather like a mausoleum where
they're the dead gold is sitting waiting
for people to remember it could be doing
exciting reactions and so on we're in
the vault the bullion vaults of the Bank
of England I've never seen so much gold
in fact I've never seen so much of any
element so we're standing here and each
shelf here has got a ton of gold which
is worth 35 million pounds at today's
price tomorrow it might be worth even
bought it's very secure we've been
through a whole series of security
checks no monies allowed here to make
sure we don't take anything out and so
we're both really excited to be here so
the camera may be shaking with brady's
excitement I never seen large lumps of
gold and to see it all round is
extraordinary one's first reaction is
that it can't possibly be real because
normally you don't see such things
looks like chocolates in the duty-free
at the airport or something like that
but these really are solid gold bars and
it's quite extraordinary
there isn't any smell because metals
don't smell and it's very quiet because
of the thick walls and to keep it secure
the weather's been very cold recently
and I was ready to be shivering but it's
nice and warm but I suppose gold colour
also gives you a feeling of warmth so it
may be partly psychological the reason
why the bank has got this store is
because not only the Bank of England but
other central banks like to keep some of
their money reserves in gold because the
price of gold is very stable or the
value of gold compared to the value of
currencies which can go up and down and
so every country has a certain
proportion of its reserves in
golde and if you look at the statistics
the UK at the moment has about 310 tons
of gold in its reserves but there's much
more gold here than that because it
belongs to all sorts of people not just
at the Bank of England this vault is
part of a complex of different rooms I
haven't seen the other rooms but
altogether if you look at the bank's
annual report it's worth a hundred and
ninety seven billion pounds that is one
hundred and ninety seven thousand
million pounds and that's quite a
serious sum of money they people buy and
sell the gold and each block of gold has
its own number like your car has a
registration number and when people bind
and trade the gold they don't actually
take the bar home but just that numbers
transferred from the sellers account to
the buyers account and the gold just
sits here quietly
apparently the oldest bar of gold here
has been here since 1916 that's the
first world war nearly a hundred years
ago but the beauty of gold as a chemical
element is that it's very unreactive so
it looks just the same now as it did in
1916 it hasn't tarnished it hasn't got
oxide layers on the surface it hasn't
started creeping changing its shape and
so on so come over here because they've
given me two bars that we can look at so
we've got two different bars of gold
which are both the so-called London good
Delivery bars which means that their
weight is in a certain limit range and
in fact each of them has its precise
weights put on them in a rather strange
unit called a troy ounce so this one is
three hundred and ninety nine point one
zero zero this one was made in Australia
and this one apparently came from
Switzerland and is slightly heavier four
hundred point seven five I must say this
one looks much nicer it's polished more
and this one looks a bit like a loaf of
bread
but is rather miserable loaf of bread
but pretty fantastic lamp of gold now
one of the things you know about gold is
that it's really heavy so I'm going to
see whether I can actually lift this
with one hand and I can sort of lift it
but not easily two hands is quite easy
so this weighs each of these in more
understandable units weighs something
like twelve point four kilos or
twenty-eight pounds so for those of you
who use imperial units that's two stone
each of these is worth about four
hundred and thirty five thousand pounds
you could buy two quite nice houses for
a block like this or for a whole shelf
of these which contains a ton you could
buy a hundred and thirty seven of the
upmarket rolls-royce cars so take your
choice these blocks are a bit like
bricks and if you took all the gold that
had ever been mined and put them
together like a construction kit to make
a big block you would end up with a
block that was 20 meters cubed that 60
feet on each side which would easily fit
for example under the legs of the Eiffel
Tower wouldn't look all that big just as
a building on the street and that's all
the gold there ever has been I did a
little calculation on the way here there
I weigh about the same as six of these
bars of gold which means that if I were
worth my weight in gold
I'd be worth a bit over two and a half
million pounds I was a bit disappointed
thought I might be worth more but still
so not only would all the gold ever
mined to fit here under the legs of the
Eiffel Tower
it had fit here quite easily by my
reckoning that cube of about 20 meters
in each direction would probably fit
three times from there to over there
same for each side and you could
probably stack it on top a few times as
well so not that much gold now we
actually filmed a bit more in the vault
we haven't used so stay tuned we might
use that soon in the meantime we've made
plenty of other films about gold
we've evaporated it we've dissolved it
you can check them out also